[MUSIC PLAYING]
WILLIAM VAMBENEPE: This
is one of the two big data
sessions for today.
We're starting now.
I'm William Vambenepe.
I'm a product manager on
Google Cloud Platform.
More specifically, I'm
responsible for big data
services on the platform.
And with me today is Jim Caputo.
He's the engineering
manager for BigQuery.
So speaking of
big data, when you
talk with industry
analysts about big data,
there's two factors which
are most often listed
as explaining the
growth of big data.
We believe there's a
third one, which is just
as important [? and getting ?]
more important every day.
And we'd like to
talk about that.
So the two which
are usually agreed
are, first, the increase in
the availability of data.
And that takes many forms--
one, of course, being the fact
that most business
transactions now
go through [INAUDIBLE]
program and generate data.
Another [INAUDIBLE] transaction.
A huge number of
[INAUDIBLE] times
that include [INAUDIBLE]
go through [? computer ?]
programs, and a lot
of data is generated
that can be [INAUDIBLE] and
help document what happens.
At the same time, there is
an ever-increasing number
of devices, from
cellphones to cars,
and then things like sensors,
objects whose only goal in life
is to produce data.
That's the only thing they
do, is just pump out data
all the time, and there's more
and more of them every day,
every month, every year.
Fortunately, the cost of
collecting and storing
all these data is coming
down dramatically as well.
So all those three
factors together,
that explains the much
larger availability of data.
The second widely
recognized reason
and factor explaining
the growth of big data
is the increase in the ability
to process data at this scale.
And this, too, comes
in three main aspects.
One of them is the invention
of new programming models, more
famously MapReduce, and
now some newer large scale
[INAUDIBLE] programming models,
which were built specifically
to allow people to
process data at a very
large scale in parallel easily.
The flip side of
that is, in addition
to inventing new
programming models,
we've taken existing well known
familiar, popular methods,
SQL chiefly, and
created services
that allow SQL to work
at a much larger scale,
and much faster than it was
designed to do originally.
And then finally, there's
been a huge explosion
in the availability of open
source software in general,
but specifically for big data.
And that has really
given everybody
a wide portfolio of
products they can use,
high quality
portfolio, something
that with a constant innovation,
very, very dynamic environment,
with products like Hadoop
and Spark and others.
And that has really
democratized and brought
down the cost of big data.
So all those together, that
has really improved the ability
to process data at large scale.
Combining that with the
availability of data,
these are the two well
understood reasons
why big data is
really picking up.
The third one, and the one
which I would submit is just
as important and becoming
even more important
and today's [INAUDIBLE]--
and the keynote this morning,
I think, has made
that very clear--
is the emergence of the cloud
consumption model for big data.
One aspect of that is how
easily it lets you get started.
You can wake up one
morning with an idea,
and by the end of the day,
even if the idea involves
processing terabytes of
data, you've tried it.
You've iterated it.
You've tested it.
Maybe you've [INAUDIBLE]
or you've refined it.
You've already been
able to do work with it
and make progress without having
to start by thinking about,
can I do it?
What do I need?
How do I get infrastructure?
You just go do it.
Whether it's a one-day
personal project
or a one-week, two-week
proof of concept,
you can right away
start using systems,
and do that at a
very, very low cost.
And then, for those
ideas and projects
that actually prove to be useful
that you want to take forward,
where you are
already in the cloud,
you can scale those
pretty much infinitely
and keep doing that
at a very, very, very
low cost of ownership.
I think [INAUDIBLE]
hopefully you
were all here early
in the morning
when Urs talked about
the price drops.
And he made it clear, this
is not a one-time price drop.
This is a continuous effort to
really bring the cost on cloud
as low as allowed by the
declining cost of hardware.
So cloud is the cheapest
place for big data,
and it will remain the cheapest
place and most effective place
for big data processing.
And finally, the third aspect
of the cloud [INAUDIBLE]
for big data is that on
a platform like Google,
you have a chance of using a mix
of platform-provided services,
fully hosted, fully managed, as
well as open source software.
And it's not one or the other.
You use them together.
They share the same data.
They share the same
authentication system.
It's one environment,
where you can seamlessly
make use of one or the other,
use them together, transition
between them.
And that's one aspect that
we're going to illustrate today.
So we have two
sessions on big data.
In this session, we'll
focus on BigQuery.
And Jim is going to describe
new features, new scalability
achievements, more detail
about a new pricing model.
And as he describes all that,
keep in mind, everything
he's describing, you get
that with no installation,
no configuration, no monitoring.
You just come, send your
query, get your result.
That's it.
This is the best
of a fully hosted,
the easiest to use, most
productive services.
And then, at the
same time, we'll
have at 3:30 here in the
same room another session all
dedicated to running
open source big data
processing software on
Google Cloud Platform.
And there, we're
going to show how
the quality of the
infrastructure,
the compute, the
storage, the network,
give you excellent
performance and excellent cost
performance running open
[? source beta ?] software.
We'll talk about
something that we've
done to implement-- [INAUDIBLE]
to implement open source
APIs to natively connect
with the sources.
We'll talk about some tooling
that we've put in place.
We'll describe in
detail how much value
you can get from running open
source software for big data
at Google.
And keep in mind, between
these two sessions-- hopefully
you'll be able to attend both--
this is really one platform.
We've broken it in
two sessions, but it's
one dataset, one
environment for you
to bring your
[? big data ?] processing.
So for now, I'll
yield to Jim, and he's
going to give us all the
goodies about BigQuery.
JIM CAPUTO: Thanks.
Thanks, William,
and thanks everybody
for coming this morning.
I'm really excited to be here
to tell you about the latest
innovations we've got
going on at BigQuery.
So we launched BigQuery a
little under two years ago,
May of 2012.
And what we brought to
market for the first time
was the ability to scan
multi-terabyte datasets
in just seconds.
This capability was
previously unheard of.
This unlocked a whole new
set of use cases, the ability
to finally do interactive
analysis over huge datasets.
We combine that with
tremendous ease of use.
No provisioning, as
William was talking about.
No figuring out how many
machines do I need to do this,
how many cores would
it take to process
a terabyte of data in seconds.
And we make it
convenient, right?
The convenience of SQL and open
interfaces like a REST API,
web user experience, SQL-92
compatible, ODBC driver.
And finally, we introduced this
notion of big data storage.
We wanted to improve
the experience
around how you actually
interact and manage your data.
Most of the large data
processing, big data
processing, is done
on large files,
large quantities of files.
We felt like a familiar
database structure
is what people really
wanted, though.
They wanted easier
data management.
They wanted to be able to
ACL and share their data.
After all, you're moving all
this data into the cloud.
Shouldn't it be
easier to collaborate
with your coworkers?
And we made it easy and fast to
get your data into the system.
So we've been hard at work
over the last two years,
and we've added quite a few
pieces of new functionality
along the way.
Shortly after launch, we
introduced batch processing.
So you have the ability to
queue up all of your jobs,
and then we would
just run them when
idle resources were available.
Clearly not every
use case requires
interactive performance.
The Excel connector made
it easy to use Excel
as your primary front
end, if you desired,
and then use BigQuery as your
primary big data back end.
I've got a lot more
in terms of partners
to talk about in a moment.
Next, we added JSON
import, in addition
to sort of standard CSV imports.
JSON's obviously valuable,
pretty ubiquitous standard
in terms of moving data around.
But more importantly,
it unlocked
nested and repeated
fields for us,
which is a pretty powerful,
although admittedly
a little bit complex, data
structure to make use of.
We also made it possible
to bring data stores.
If you have a Cloud
Datastore instance,
you can back that up, and then
bring it right into BigQuery
for analysis.
Or as mentioned earlier, at
the beginning of last year,
Big JOIN, the ability to join
two arbitrarily large datasets
together, regardless of JOIN
key that you're operating on.
Big aggregates, the ability
to group on something
that has potentially
millions of distinct values.
So for instance, you're
grouping on something
like user ID, that's
going to scale
with the size of your system.
And then time stamps.
So we're furthering that goal of
making this more database-like.
A standard timestamp data type,
and the company functions that
would go with that.
After that, large query results.
So not only were you able to
query data of unlimited size,
you can now generate
data of unlimited size.
So all of a sudden,
we started seeing
more and more use
cases emerging.
We started with that interactive
analysis, started seeing people
doing more ETL processing, for
instance, on top of BigQuery.
Query caching, just to help
out application development,
reduce costs,
speed things along.
Analytic functions.
We continue to invest
in our SQL engine.
Near the end of last
year, the streaming API.
It actually launched
with 100 rows per second
initially, combined
with that feature you
saw that Eric demonstrated,
with table decorators.
So the ability to
just slice into-- I
only want to see the last two
hours of data, for instance.
At the end of last year,
Google Analytics integration.
I'll talk more about
this in a moment.
And finally, today, a bunch
of new features coming out.
We've dramatically increased
the streaming rate,
as Eric showed you, up to
100,000 rows per table now.
Table views, again, extending on
that goal of advanced big data
storage.
We want this easy to use.
We want you to be able
to reuse this stuff
and share large queries across
your organization more easily.
Table wild cards.
So also mentioned this
morning, the ability
to very easily shard your
data across many tables.
We want to make that easy to
use from a query perspective.
So for instance,
if you've chosen
to shard your data
across days, you
may want to use a wild card
that says give me that table,
and here's the date
range I want to apply.
Automatically just
works for you.
JSON functions.
So if you've loaded up a bunch
of JSON in a given field,
you can use a JSON function
to extract out values
automatically.
And finally, a whole bunch
of other SQL improvements,
trying to make us much
more closely aligned
with the standard
SQL-92 spec, as well
as a whole bunch of
additional improvements,
like some of those
analytical functions.
So it's not just us.
The ecosystem around us has been
going at an incredible speed.
We've really been
impressed by this.
We've got a great partnership,
for instance, with Tableau.
We've spent quite a
bit of time working
on the technical
integration there.
We've been able to
see whole new use
cases emerging in
that space as well.
Actually bringing
interactive performance
to a visualization and data
analysis tool like that
has been tremendous.
I saw a great
example of pandas--
so Python and
analytical functions
done there in the
open source community.
As you can see, a whole
bunch of other providers
all working around us.
So thanks for all your
efforts out on the open source
and partner community.
We're sort of excited to
see where this can go next,
building on top of
the BigQuery platform.
So BigQuery streaming.
Let's dive into this
a little bit further.
As demoed this morning, we
can do 100,000 rows per table
at a low cost of just one penny
per 100,000 rows in real time
availability of that data.
This dramatically simplifies
the amount of infrastructure
that you have to build
and maintain on your side.
No longer do you need
to batch up records,
figure out when you
want to submit those,
and at what latency
or frequency they're
going to come into the system.
And the use cases
are endless here.
So for starters, you can see an
example like that distributed
application that Eric built.
But we're starting to see
other examples emerging.
And working with a
customer, Streak,
one of our early adopters,
they were impressed by this.
They were able to use
streaming to reduce
the amount of
infrastructure, of course,
to simplify the
infrastructure to bring
their data into the system.
And so great, they
were able to continue
using their standard reporting.
What they found were new
cases, new use cases emerging.
All of a sudden, they had
user support scenarios
that would come in.
And rather than have
to go to one system end
to figure out the
debug logs, they
could go to a single
system, look at the debug
logs right alongside what
was the historical behavior
for this customer.
What was their user experience
in the last month or so?
So we think this is the
best of both worlds.
It gives you the flexibility
to do that real time processing
that you desire
when you need it,
that low latency processing,
while also bringing that data
into a storage system
that's capable of doing
your full historical analysis.
So there's nothing
disjoint here.
Everything is all
done in one location.
Moving on, next, I'd
like to deep dive
for sure into Google Analytics.
For the first time,
Google Analytics customers
are now capable of bringing
in completely unsampled,
row-by-row detail of
their analytics data.
This was previously unavailable.
And the volume of data
here is tremendous.
Bringing this data
into the system
is done completely
for you automatically
via managed pipeline
behind the scenes.
Bringing this data in couldn't
be any easier for you.
All you need to do is sign up
for Google Analytics Premium.
The data automatically
arrives on a daily basis.
So we've already seen
quick adoption here.
The number of use cases
are essentially endless.
And talking with some
of our early customers
and website owners, the first
thing they were amazed by
is the volume of data
that they could actually
analyze inside of BigQuery.
No longer were they looking
at month over month changes.
They were looking at
year over year changes,
over many years,
something just previously
they couldn't actually
endeavor to do.
Secondarily, we've seen
quickly customers are actually
uploading their transactional
information, which
is pretty exciting.
Because now they can do those
big joins, those data mashups.
They can actually
look at, in this case,
the customer is interested
in trying to figure out
why are some users spending
a fair amount of money
on their site, they come
back, but they're not
repeating their purchases.
What changed?
And then there's
another example as well.
So the value here
is incredibly high.
We've seen tremendous adoption.
In just a few months, a
whole bunch of huge customers
have been coming
online, huge data
volumes and
interesting use cases.
So I wanted to look
at a few other use
cases I found interesting.
Interactions marketing.
Interactions does
on-site retail marketing.
So they're actually
out at storefronts
doing marketing campaigns.
So actually, maybe a
sample of some sort
that they're distributing.
And they wanted to
understand the answer
to what I thought was a pretty
straightforward question.
They wanted to understand
what's the impact of weather
and weather events on these
retail marketing campaigns.
As it turns out,
their analysts had
struggled to do this
for quite some time.
The data volumes
were just too large.
They couldn't perform
that data mashup.
But I love this quote
here from Giovanni.
He says, "Analyses would require
hours or days to complete.
With Google, it
took just minutes."
This timed insight was
previously impossible.
So using the power of Tableau
as their front end and BigQuery
as their big data back
end, deriving insights
that were previously
not possible to generate
in the past.
This next one came from
Shine Technologies.
I was really interested
to learn more about this.
In fact, they're
here today, so I'm
excited to have them
in the audience here.
So Graham actually posted a
tweet a couple of months ago
and said, hey, we've
been really successful
with this BigQuery product.
What it turned out
was, they were actually
struggling in the past to do
the data analysis they needed
to do on running on just a
small sample of the dataset
that they had in question.
They're using ad serving logs,
so huge numbers of impressions
and counts that they were trying
to push through the system.
And they were amazed.
In a two hour proof
of concept effort,
they went from getting the data
loaded to immediately being
able to answer questions that
were previously impossible.
I love the last line here.
He says, "The SQL-like query
language is an easy transition
to make for any engineer
and much quicker and easier
than using a MapReduce model."
Again, simplicity
along with scale.
We're trying to drive both
of these at the same time.
So I mentioned we started with
this arguably relatively narrow
offering.
It was high performance,
really fast,
but it wasn't really intended
to solve for something as
big as data warehousing.
Well, that's definitely changed
over the last two years.
Our friends over
at Motorola have
made huge use of the
system and are using it
as their primary data
warehouse for some
of their most important data.
So to walk through this,
their most important data
is their telemetry data
that they're collecting off
all of their devices
out there, obviously
hundreds of millions
of Motorola phones.
They ship this data up through
App Engine multiple times
per day.
App Engine does some
lightweight preprocessing,
and then drops it into cloud
storage for archival purposes.
Which is fine, but it's
not particularly actionable
sitting there.
They instead, as
quickly as possible,
move that data over
to BigQuery storage,
where they can begin
to take action on it.
Well, Motorola was
running the majority
of their data processing
in-house previously.
They had a rather
large Hadoop instance
on their own private cluster.
And they came to us
less than a year ago
and really started investing
in the cloud platform.
As it turns out, they went
from basically 0 bytes
in BigQuery a little
over a year ago to now
having many petabytes
of data in storage.
And they actually are still
using those same Hadoop
MapReduces.
So they're running
those MapReduces now
on top of the logs that have
been brought into BigQuery
storage and generating
the downstream tables
they need for
analysts to consume.
On top of that, we've seen
them actually migrating
a decent number of their
workflows over to BigQuery.
So MapReduce is great
in some instances,
SQL solves for other cases.
Might be simpler to use
in some circumstances.
And then finally, once that
data is all processed and ready
for use, it's moved
downstream in general for all
of their analysts
to take advantage
of, hundreds of analysts
around the company
running queries all
day long, building
applications,
visualizations, dashboards.
So whereas previously we assumed
that BigQuery was primarily
intended as an
analytics engine, now
we're seeing it
expanding, seeing
it going into this
data warehousing role.
So I've harped on
this quite a bit now.
BigQuery storage.
It's more than
just file storage.
We've invested in
it quite a bit,
and we continue to
make improvements.
It's, of course,
everything you would
expect from cloud-based
storage, right?
It's highly available,
highly durable.
It uses an optimized
columnar format underneath,
something we've built
proprietary inside Google
specifically for this workload.
And we take those files
that have been imported,
and we actually do quite
a bit of management
on top of those for
you on your behalf.
So for instance, if
you have happened
to import a whole
bunch of small files,
we'll actually automatically
coalesce those over time
to ensure that we get the
highest possible query
throughput.
And we offer fast table
reads, the ability to read
data out of that storage
layer without running a query.
It's rich metadata.
As I said, a familiar
database-like structure,
datasets, tables, full fields
and schemas, as well as
descriptions we just added
in this latest release
for each one of those.
A time to live on tables.
Maybe you only want to store
90 days' worth of data.
You can just expire
tables after 90 days.
Project and dataset level ACLs,
so very fine-grained controls.
And table decorators.
Maybe another interesting
use case of table decorators
to highlight-- imagine,
over the last two days,
you discover that
your imports were
bringing in corrupted data.
You could actually reference the
table as it was two days ago,
make a copy of it, rerun the
imports with your corrected
data, and off you go.
Very easy to interact with.
And finally, data imports.
We've invested heavily in the
standard, high-frequency bulk
imports.
We've obviously got
this new improvement now
with the streaming API.
And we couldn't make it any
easier with respect to data
feeds like Google Analytics.
So BigQuery storage.
It's, of course,
optimized for SQL.
That's the primary interface
that we've exposed to you
all, and we continue
to make investments
in terms of new functions.
JSON_EXTRACT is an
interesting example here.
So this might open up a
whole new set of use cases.
You have your JSON
data somewhere.
You just bring it
directly into BigQuery.
You can preprocess it and then
generate downstream tables
that you want to run
your analytics on.
So it's a structured
data repository,
but a very flexible one.
With this JSON
processing, you can
add a lot of value to
the data right there.
You can do these
large, arbitrary joins.
And you have nested
and repeated fields.
Complex, as I said
earlier, but very powerful.
So let's take a
closer look at that.
I'm going to use the
analytics data here
to look at nested
and repeated fields.
So analytics applies quite
a bit of business logic
to all of the hits that are
uploaded throughout the day.
It's collecting every single
hit, of course, that somebody
has on a given website,
with the general goal being
they want to generate this
notion of a visit or a session.
So all of these
hits encapsulated
for a given visitor that's
arrived at the system.
So their schema looks
something like this.
They have at the top
level of a row or a record
this notion of a visit ID,
and a visit start time,
and a couple of other fields.
And then, embedded within
that, an array of hits.
And within each one of
those is a hit's time,
so the offset from
the start time,
and the path, the
actual URL of the hit,
and a whole bunch of
other fields as well.
And then just thought I'd note
here, yet another repeated
field embedded in there
for custom variables,
if the website
owner set those up.
And those would hang
off of the hits array.
So what does this
actually look like here?
So we actually run
Google Analytics
right on top of that
BigQuery user experience
that you're able to use.
So I pulled out a single visit
here from early February.
Looking at a few here,
I notice the user
went from github_nested, one
of our public data samples,
and then moved to the
timeline version of that,
and then kind of
proceeded around
to various different
tables there.
So they're sort of exploring,
clearly, and trying
to get a sense of what do
those different tables-- what
can they do with those.
So I started thinking about
an interesting use case.
I was kind of wondering,
how many people
have done the same thing, or how
many people have transitioned,
for instance, from github_nested
to github_timeline?
How would I go about
solving that question?
And maybe that's
a bit contrived,
but you can imagine this in a
given e-commerce site-- maybe
a travel website.
You're looking at a
hotel details page,
and you want to
see how long does
it take for people to
transition from the details page
over to the purchase page.
OK, that might be a little more
interesting in that scenario.
Maybe something's
changed, or maybe it
varies by region or by
hotel, and maybe you
need to change your
marketing on those pages.
So I set out to write this.
I wanted to find the average
duration spent transitioning
from page A to page B, in this
case, those two GitHub tables.
And as it turns out,
the SQL for this
was significantly
more complicated
than I was actually expecting.
So I apologize.
This is a bit of an eye chart.
I realize that.
But I want to go
through the specifics
here and explain how
this actually works.
So in the innermost
query here, we
need to pull out the
visit ID, the hit time,
and the actual path
that was navigated to.
The next bit of syntax
is OMIT RECORD IF.
It's actually something I
wasn't even familiar with prior
to trying to work
on this example.
What it does is rather than just
apply a standard WHERE clause,
OMIT IF allows me to find
rows in which, embedded
in that repeated field of
hits, both of those conditions
have been met.
In this case, the
user navigated to
both github_nested
and github_timeline.
So now that I have
at least the rows
that I'm interested
in processing,
I need to find those
cases where they actually
did transition between
those two specific tables.
So I come here, and I use one
of those analytic functions,
a combination of
partition by, ordering
on hit time, and
this notion of lead.
And what it's essentially
doing is it's transposing.
It's taking hit number one, and
it's transposing hit number two
alongside of it, and
so on and so forth.
Once I have that
created, using path
and now path lead as the two
fields as I've named them,
I can now apply this
final outer select.
First it's filtering,
of course, and it's
looking for a path as
github_nested and path lead
as github_timeline.
And then I can do the
count and the average.
So this works.
This definitely works.
There's no doubt about it.
And you can construct all
sorts of amazing things,
especially if you've
been using SQL for years.
But I would argue, clearly
SQL has some challenges.
I mean, these limits, if
not nearly impossible,
in some cases are
truly impossible.
And so I don't think
this is anything new.
I mean, other databases
have solved for this, right?
There's PL/SQL, there's T-SQL.
This is pretty standard
in the industry.
People have accepted that
sometimes a procedural language
makes life 1,000 times easier.
Even if you can
express it in SQL,
it might be that much easier
to express your business
logic in a procedural language.
So what would this one
look like if I just
want to find those hits?
Let's isolate in on that
most important part.
It's super straightforward.
For each row here, I
have an array of hits.
I just need to check if hits
sub i is equal to github_nested,
and hits sub i plus 1 is equal
to github_timeline, then do
something.
In this case, I'm adding to
an array and omitting it.
So it's clearly a
lot easier, right?
I need this escape hatch.
I need this ability to
be able to go operate
in more arbitrary
ways than I can
express in SQL in some cases.
And I mentioned earlier
that we make this possible.
You can do reads directly
from BigQuery storage
without running a query.
In fact, I noted that
Motorola was actually
doing MapReduces over
BigQuery storage.
So what we're announcing as
well today is not only can
you do those reads,
but you can now
do them at incredibly
high throughput.
We're making it possible
to read in parallel
across a huge BigQuery table
via Hadoop, via whatever
parallel processing tool
you have of your choosing.
The pseudocode
here I've included,
it's trivial to set this up.
You first need to instruct
BigQuery via an API call
that you want to read in
parallel across a given table.
You tell us the number of
workers you're going to have.
Maybe you're going to run
100 MapReduce workers.
You then wait for
that job to start.
Should take no more
than a few seconds.
And then you would iterate.
Each partition could be consumed
in parallel across that table.
So this unlocks a whole
new set of use cases.
But maybe there's
an even easier way.
And if you can switch
to the demo, please.
Apologies.
It's pulling up
the wrong desktop.
The question is which one.
A little help.
I'm on desktop four.
How do I get to desktop four?
A-ha.
Much better.
Hopefully you all can read
that from the back row.
It might be a little bit small.
So what you're
looking at here, I
mentioned we have the
github_nested table
alongside the
github_timeline table.
So here I just
induce this behavior.
I've navigated between the two.
And I've pulled in all
of our analytics data
into this test dataset here.
So we can take a quick
look there as well.
So we have visit ID
and visit start time,
like I was talking about.
A whole bunch of
other fields here,
totals, traffic source,
the device that you've
navigated from, as well as
that repeated field of hits.
So hits, and the hit
time, and the page path.
And this table isn't
particularly large here.
It's about 18 gigs,
about 11 million rows.
So I mentioned there
might be an easier way.
Well, indeed, there is.
We are combining the power of
that procedural language right
inside the power of BigQuery,
the full scalability
of BigQuery, allowing you
to merge right together
both SQL and JavaScript
at the same time.
And like that, I've run
that exact same query,
now directly inside
BigQuery, without any effort
in terms of spinning up
resources, provisioning
hardware, or doing any kind of
software provisioning as well.
So taking a closer look here,
it's pretty straightforward.
We've got a standard SQL
select at the top here
pulling from that given table.
The next row, I'm
instructing BigQuery
what is going to be the input
schema I'm interested in.
So which fields do I want
to pull out of that table.
The following row is
what's the schema that's
going to be omitted
from the function.
And then, as you can
see, the function itself.
And I would argue, going
back to that can you
push the limits with SQL,
what are the boundaries there.
Let's take a slightly
different example.
Maybe I don't want
to look specifically
at that transition
from github_nested
to timeline immediately,
but I'd like
to see if they skipped a
page or two in between.
So changing that is as simple
as coming through here,
making a quick update.
It's very easy at least
for me to understand this
relative to the
challenge I think
I would endure in
trying to figure out
how to do this in SQL.
So off it runs.
This is coming soon.
We're going to make it
available to you-- excuse me.
Please contact a sales
rep to get started.
Hopefully this will
finish here in a moment.
[INAUDIBLE] indeed it does.
Please, let's switch
back to the slide.
So with BigQuery and the
combination of both SQL and now
JavaScript UDFs, we
think we're unlocking
a whole set of new use cases.
We're very excited to see
what you guys can come up
with next on this.
So BigQuery storage.
In summary, it's optimized
for SQL, of course.
And we're going to
continue to invest there.
We have a whole bunch of
new improvements coming down
the road.
Fast table reads,
the new ability
to do huge scale MapReduce
directly against a BigQuery
table, not having to necessarily
do any operations in between.
And finally, coming
soon, JavaScript
UDFs on top of
BigQuery data directly.
So the last area
I wanted to cover
are those pricing announcements.
We talked about those this
morning in the keynote.
We're definitely excited about
opening this up more broadly
to more users.
So why are we doing this?
Well, of course, to reduce
price, lower barrier to entry.
We want more people.
We want everyone to have
access to big data processing.
We've also heard from the
larger customers we have,
they really wanted
predictability
in terms of cost.
Additionally, we've seen
these new usage models
emerging since we started.
So data warehousing,
now streaming ingestion,
doing real time capabilities,
and UDFs coming along the way
soon.
So lower across the board,
everything is coming down.
So lower query pricing,
$5 per terabyte,
an 85% reduction off of our
current $35 price point.
Lower storage pricing, $26
per terabyte per month,
65% reduction.
And what's really
important to note here
is that your storage
pricing is completely
independent from
your query pricing.
So you can park as
much data as you
want with this at
bare bones pricing
and not necessarily have to
pay a dime in query costs.
Use it as much or as little
as you want in terms of query.
It's immediately available.
Only Google has
the infrastructure,
in terms of storage, network,
and query capability,
to give you these
things independently.
And finally, lower
streaming costs,
one penny per 100,000 rows.
We've actually deferred
pricing on this until July
to let you get started now.
So on demand query pricing,
a closer look at this.
This is essentially our
existing usage model.
It's ideal for interactive
ad hoc analysis.
It leverages a very large
shared pool of resources.
Because it is a shared pool,
we do impose these limits
in terms of how much
a single user can
use, making sure everybody
gets their fair share
of those resources.
Pricing is simple, $5
per terabyte processed,
no contracts, pay as you go.
Doesn't get any easier.
But Urs also
mentioned this morning
we have a whole new pricing
model coming online.
It's reserve capacity.
It gives predictable
costs for those larger
workloads, consistent
performance,
and we remove those
concurring query quotas.
You choose how much capacity
you need to send as many queries
as you like.
So capacity reservations, the
purchase in increments of 5
gigabytes per second.
Something that's relatively
easy to get your head
wrapped around.
How much do I want in
terms of throughput?
Not how many machines do I need
to buy, how many cores do I
need, do I need SSD
versus regular disks,
what do I need to do?
Larger, more
consistent workloads
is what this is
after, obviously,
with a monthly commitment
attached to it.
Each 5 gigabyte per
second increment
costs $20,000 per month and
enables 13,000 terabytes
of processing per month.
If you were to
fully utilize that,
that's actually a
95% price reduction
off our current $35 price point.
So what is 13,000
terabytes, though?
That sounds big,
but I'm not really
sure what it means in reality.
So I put together a quick
example customer scenario here.
Let's imagine you have 50
terabytes of data stored,
and your average query size
is about 2 and 1/2 terabytes.
Right off the gate,
you might question
why just 5% of my data?
Why is it so small?
Well, I mentioned earlier
columnar data format.
It's very highly optimized.
We reduce the amount
of data scanned simply
based on the columns referenced.
So if you had 50
columns in the table,
and you're only referencing five
of those, probably about 10%
of your data is actually going
to be scanned in that query.
But there's other
places you can save.
So table partitioning and
using Table Wildcards.
If you have daily tables, and
you only need to query over
seven days, then only reference
seven days' worth of data.
You don't need to
reference the whole year.
Or additionally,
Table Decorators
if you're doing more
recent information
that you want to pull out.
Maybe you have
the streaming API.
So there's many ways in
which you can get there.
In fact, a lot of our customers
see a lot lower than 5%
in some of their use cases.
So I'm also going to imagine
that this company has
two analysts that they
want to have operating
on this particular dataset,
and those analysts are going
to run about 75 queries per day.
So in total, that's
2.5 terabytes
times 150 queries, about
375 terabytes of processing
per day.
As it turns out, our
smallest reservation
can accommodate a
50 terabyte dataset.
Because a single reservation
of 5 gigabytes per second
enables you to do 432 terabytes
of processing per day.
So quite a bit of
capability just
from the smallest
reservation increment.
The other thing that
we enable, because
of BigQuery's
multi-tenant architecture,
is the ability to not only
use your reserve capacity,
but optionally burst into
our on demand resource pool.
This is something nobody
else is capable of doing.
The scenarios here are endless.
So it might be just during
the course of a given day,
there's volatility
in your workloads.
And you want to have the ability
to spike, and not necessarily
have all of your users
backed up and waiting.
Or maybe the finance
team is struggling
to get financials done at
the end of the quarter.
Or maybe literally you're
just increasing your volumes
that dramatically,
and you haven't
figured out how much more
you want to provision,
but you need the capability
to run more queries.
So it offers that
predictability in cost
with guaranteed capacity
and additional resources
when you need them.
So what does this actually
look like in practice?
This is going to get a little
in depth with some charts here,
but this should be fun.
So here's a given
day's worth of volume.
And you can imagine it wouldn't
be a perfect bell curve,
but as you might guess,
the volume's going
to increase during the middle
of the day for a given work day,
right?
And so this curve is measuring
query throughput, essentially
the number of queries you're
pushing into the system
at any given time
for your reservation.
In this case, using
that customer example,
the total query
processing during that day
was 375 terabytes.
So that customer reserved
5 gigabytes per second.
And they've chosen
not to actually burst.
That's where they started out.
They felt like that was
the appropriate approach.
And this is what you would
get if you were provisioning
your own hardware or
buying or reserving
n number of instances.
You would get something
that looks like this.
Rather than the
smooth bell curve,
you would end up
capping your capacity.
All of your queries
would start slowing down.
Your users would get
a worse experience.
And then hopefully, at some
point near the end of the day,
the system catches
up and recovers
in the middle of the night,
and then eventually you
come back, and the
same experience again.
We've all experienced this.
Oh, the SQL server
is running slow today
because there's a lot of
workload going on, right?
But with BigQuery, you don't
need to run into this problem.
In our case, we're
able to actually burst
that additional need above and
beyond your reserved instance.
Ironically, the query
capacity requires the same.
We still have 375 terabytes of
processing to do in that day.
The difference is
your users didn't
have to bump into those
painful slowdowns.
So this is burst with cap.
There was no change.
And I'll explain
cap in a moment.
In the next example, they've
also chosen burst with cap,
but over time, their
data volumes have grown.
The number of queries
they're running is higher.
So they're spending
the vast majority
of their time above
their reservation,
more than they've reserved
in terms of query throughput.
So what happens in this case,
because they've told us,
they said we can't go beyond
our $20,000 per month budget,
we're actually going to
stop them at some point.
We're going to stop
them technically
at 432 terabytes
in that given day.
They could, of course, go
outside the reservation
and still run on demand queries.
I want to be clear about that.
But they have told us--
they've instructed us,
they don't want to
go beyond that cap.
And then finally,
the last example.
This case, they haven't figured
out exactly how much more they
want to reserve, but
the last thing they want
is their queries to get blocked.
So they're allowing
this to go through.
They're going to process, in
this example, 510 terabytes.
So a number of scenarios there.
And I realize that might
be a bit complicated,
but I'm trying to highlight
the tremendous amount
of flexibility we're bringing.
The first scenario is
perhaps the most obvious one.
This is what most people
face on a given day.
They buy a fixed
amount of capacity.
They're capped at that capacity.
Perhaps there's
some benefit here
you would avoid if
you were truly capped
in terms of budget.
You would avoid consuming
too many resources
too early on in the day.
The second scenario,
they ran over the top
of the reservation, but
they still [INAUDIBLE]
consume the exact same number
of terabytes in processing.
So there was no additional cost.
Third scenario,
they did a burst,
and they actually
burst it too far along.
But they got more.
They actually got 430 terabytes.
They told us the cap, so the
additional cost, again, is $0.
And then finally, in
the last scenario,
they ran a total
of 510 terabytes,
roughly 80 terabytes more.
We multiply that by the
standard on demand rate
for an extra $400 that day.
So we believe that
BigQuery is finally
realizing the true benefits
of cloud here-- simplicity,
the performance you desire,
and the scalability you
need whenever you need it.
So in conclusion,
you've seen a lot today,
both in the keynote this morning
and some of these examples
here.
We're trying to make it simpler
for you in terms of storage.
We're trying to unlock
all the use cases,
whether it be something
you want to power with SQL
or something you want to
power with a MapReduce,
or coming soon, SQL
UDFs, all merged right
inside of BigQuery.
And we've made it
tremendously easier
in terms of both cost and
provisioning, simplifying
the overall use case.
With that, thank you
so much for your time.
We look forward to seeing
more of your use cases
and working with you guys
on new business problems.
Come visit us, cloud.google.com.
Thanks.